i know who you are boy because you're
me imagine the face of the hero in your
favorite marvel movie
now imagine if that face was completely
different
the faces of the superheroes in marvel
movies have become almost as important
as their stories
we have the actors behind these faces to
thank for making our favorite
superheroes
as lovable and awesome as they are what
would the marvel movie universe look
like if other actors had been cast as
your beloved hero
instead would your favorite still be the
same
the best scripts i've ever read but i uh
i'm sure whoever does it's gonna have a
great time doing it
timothy is well known as hollywood's
freshest heartthrob but what you might
not have known about the young actor
is that he was almost cast as your
favorite spidey hero in place of tom
holland who
eventually landed the role oh you're
you're you're the you're the spider-man
you're the tom holland
right now the young actor recalls his
extreme nerves at the auditions stating
to the hollywood reporter
i read twice and i left sweating in a
total panic
i called my agent brian swardstrom and i
said
ryan i thought about this a lot and i
have to go back and knock on that door
and read again
despite all of his nerves around the
role it was determined that spider-man
wasn't quite for him and the decision to
cast tom holland was finalized
it's a dream for an actor this young
starlet had expressed a great amount of
interest in playing the scarlet witch
after marvel claimed to be using her as
the model for the role
talk about a compliment so it was kind
of a dream for me to get to like
actually live that out cersei stated
i love joss and i love those films and i
love his handle on them and how he
portrayed these kinds of superheroes
so yeah i'd love to be in it but that
didn't quite work out for the young
actress as elizabeth olsen
clearly took her place as the super
heroine instead
just imagine what wandavision might have
been like if sercia had the role instead
emily blunt was initially supposed to be
an iron man 2 as the black widow
but as fate came to have it the role
just didn't work out for the actress
she was faced with some serious
scheduling conflicts as the marvel movie
was in production at nearly
the same time as her other project
gulliver's travels
and this project won as she had a
pre-existing deal with the production
team
so ultimately due to scheduling
conflicts blunt had to pass up the role
as black widow
letting scarlett johansson swoop in and
secure the character instead
i think it went really well amandla
decided not to take this role because
she felt that it was better suited to a
dark-skinned black actress
after going through part of the audition
process she realized her mistake in
going for the role and pulled out
she stated that was really challenging
to make that decision
but i have no regrets i recognize 100
that there are spaces that i
should not take up and when i do take up
space it's because i thought
really really critically about it i'm
interested in bringing
black narratives to screen seifried
turned down the role of gamora because
of the intense body makeup
i didn't want to be green which she
recalled jennifer lawrence struggling
with for x-men
she also thought that the guardians of
the galaxy movie series would be a flop
a flop she didn't want to be associated
with she said
i didn't want to be part of the first
marvel movie that bombed i said who
wants to see a movie about a talking
tree and a raccoon which
is clearly i was very wrong
surprise another famous actress was also
considered for the character of gamora
the role of gamora was originally
offered to olivia wilde
though it has become very unclear as to
why the actress didn't take the role
she has not made any comments about why
she has passed it up or
if she had been denied the role in the
end all we know now is that zoe saldana
made an impactful performance in the
role instead
and we're grateful for that casting
choice touch me
and the only thing you're gonna feel is
a broken jaw
tom hiddleston has revealed to jimmy
fallon that he never even actually tried
out for the role of loki instead the
actor had initially auditioned to be
thor himself but was actually cast as
his adoptive brother in the end
just imagine tom hiddleston in chris
hemsworth's place
as the norse god what an odd switch that
would be
i think we can all agree that they cast
the right actor
we are definitely thankful that the two
actors ended up in the roles they did
or the marvel universe wouldn't be the
same to our surprise liam hemsworth also
tried out for the role of thor
just like his brother differently than
his sibling though
liam found a lot of success in his
initial audition
getting call backs and hearing good
responses he basically got down to last
like four people
his brother chris actually had to have
his manager negotiate with the studio
to give him a second chance in trying
out for the role talk about awkward
sibling drama
we still don't talk that much although
the actress never quite revealed which
role she had been being considered for
in the avengers
she claims to have been offered a role
which time has narrowed down
to agent maria hill the actress has said
that her manager has not pushed her
enough to land her a major role in the
film
it was an issue and it affected me in
the end this role was eventually played
by kobe smulders
when john krasinski comes to mind so
does his character jim halpert from the
office
am i right i don't think any of them
actually know my real name
krazynski made it pretty impressively
far into the audition process for
captain america
he even made it to costuming where he
tried on the captain fit
and saw cast members walking around
behind the scenes i gotta say for a
split second there i was feeling really
good about myself
it was only then did he realize for
himself that he just wasn't quite cut
out for the role
so he dropped out of the audition
process this is how my captain america
would go
hello america sebastian stan
the actor who plays bucky in captain
america wasn't always considering the
role
originally stan tried out to be captain
america or steve rogers himself
but was ultimately denied the role
instead he was offered the role of bucky
which he luckily thought was a much
better role
in the end we're just happy that he was
happy with the character
sam rockwell robert downey jr's co-star
in iron man 2 was initially offered a
spot to audition for tony stark by
director john favreau himself
he offered him a test screening as well
providing the director's original
passion for casting rockwell as the iron
man
it was a crazy experience you know this
casting choice
clearly didn't work out as rdj clearly
rocks the role better than any other
actor could
game of thrones star jason mamoa was
looking to play the guardians of the
galaxy character drax but was cut from
this opportunity
after having failed negotiations for
higher pay more than just this
mamoa wanted to diversify his casting a
little bit and keep away from the
shirtless brooding types that he has
been typecast in
over and over again hey there's no need
to get personal he decided to take his
career in a different direction and
forego the role of drax to do so
it is reported that black panther star
chadwick boseman tried out for the role
of the guardians of the galaxy character
drax
too so i didn't know what it was and i
only had you know some
a few pages wouldn't it have been insane
to see the black panther as drax instead
sadly bozeman was ultimately denied the
role with it going to dave bautista
instead
he stated that he was grateful for the
failed audition despite not landing the
role
because it paved the way for him to land
the lead of black panther in the future
i feel like that was one of the moments
when they were like hey we can use him
later
this comedic actor adam sandler was
considered for the role of rocket
raccoon
alongside other famous comedian jim
carrey what an
interesting mashup of actors the role
was eventually given to bradley cooper
in place of sandler or carrie
giving the character a bit more of a
serious note than the two comedian
actors would
probably have been able to deliver oh
that's intense
all of our favorite marvel films would
not be the same if these actors played
our favorite characters instead
the next time you watch your favorite
marvel movie imagine these actors in the
place of the ones you see on screen
and think about how big of a difference
just one
casting decision could make thanks for
watching